[Musique]
bonsoir heureux de vous retrouver pour
ce nouveau 7,8 les invités ont pas ce
titre dans son directeur du théâtre
espace pouliche de plaisir et sur notre
plateau nous ferons un point avec lui
sur la saison 2017-2018 et puis nous
recevrons cindy rodrigues elle est la
présidente du futur club de handball de
villepreux
celui ci devrait voir le jour à la
rentrée elle nous expliquera ses
objectifs
au début de ses études des invités avec
vincent desmons directeur du théâtre
espace coluche il épouse est avec nous
sur ce plateau bonsoir bonsoir merci
d'être venu je vous en prie merci à vous
alors ça a été compliqué de la mettre en
place cette programmation c'est pas
avant fin ça va être un peu prétentieux
aussi tellement compliqué puisque ça
fait 25 ans que je fais ça on
connaissait jean selles oui les ficelles
et puis surtout le le plaisir d'aller
voir plein de spectacles et puis on
commence à connaître ça fait presque dix
ans que je suis un plaisir dont je
commence à connaître un peu le
le public et puis une fois plus comme
c'est un théâtre de villas des
municipales on disait dans le temps
passé à table de ville les les objectifs
fixés par la ville par le madame le
maire sont très claires c'est saison
éclectique il en faut pour tout le monde
détail affichent des spectacles un peu
plus confidentielle mais plus
intéressant peut-être parfois
artistiquement ou encore qu'ils ont tous
à l'intérieur testing bien sûr c'est pas
bien on est d'accord c'est pas parce que
dieu le sait les affiches que c'est pas
intéressant mais parfois des choses un
peu plus voilà on a créé les puristes
voilà où non aux et la découverte on va
dire nous on appelait ça aux et la
découverte pas mal de spectacles
d'avignon la vigne on s'est vraiment
c'est le vivier c'est le vivier voilà il
y a quand même quand même faut savoir
qu'au festival off d'avignon il ya plus
de 1400 spectacle qui se joue en même
temps chaque jour donc il ya de quoi
faire je vois pas les 1400 j'envoie 40
mais d'autres c'est à bac vous faites
peut-être en passant par trois parties
et ce qui nous permet d'avoir une saison
où il y en a pour tout le monde dès les
enfants et s'est alors présentée nous un
petit peu cette saison j'ai un petit peu
et et j'ai cru voir michel drucker entre
autres n'est acquis un médecine à arnaud
gidoin non je me suis peut-être on perd
des habitants qui dope
par rapport à la tête dit moi non voilà
on a trop on débute la saison avec la
louve qui est un spectacle historique
avec béatrice agenin connu on a ensuite
on passe vraiment du coq à l'âne ou
vraiment des choses très diverses on à
bollywood masala orchestra ça sent
vraiment la peine c'est super c'est la
fête après on va en plus lourds bruno
salomone c'est bruno salomone et je vous
avez l'air de réfléchir ou le monde dont
j'ai vu le spectacle a pris alors moi
j'ai de la chance je les ai tous vus
avant mais n'empêche que le jour où ils
repassent je suis de nouveau dans la
salle danser grand plaisir de voir tout
ça bruno salomone qui est très drôle
après on a un spectacle on a une pause
de théâtre adieu monsieur atmane qui est
une pièce un peu plus est à la fois
drôle mais à la fois un peu dramatique
puisque ça se passe pendant la guerre
elle mixe à réfléchir et à la qui sait
bien et ensuite on a commandé un tribute
on avait eu l'année dernière un tribute
pour queen tt cover queen là on a cover
trempe l'impression d'avoir supertramp
sur scène enfin c'est vraiment génial
on a des pièces donc on a bien entendu
un mail si l' on a évolué vie la visite
oui c'était compliqué de le faire venir
à plaisir non comment ça se passe quand
vous les contacts et dites nous tout
alors en fait je suis souvent contactés
voilà une bonne chose parce que le
théâtre était une belle salle c'est une
salle de 900 places donc ça permet à
beaucoup ça attire les producteurs on
commence effectivement un peu à se
connaître des gens licorne a l'habitude
de travailler donc parfois je les
appelle et puis ben les échanges de
mails 1 tient bon en face avec une
contact parfois c'est moi qui les
contactent et puis du coup bas mais
d'ici là on est allé vers le spectacle
alors j'y suis allé avec les jeunes
collaborateurs
pour un métier là j'étais le papy de la
salle il faut savoir à non mais c'était
si ainsi j'étais dans parmi les plus
âgées du public
c'était très drôle mais mon
collaborateur à 25 ans et cellule
chargée de com du théâtre ou bien mal et
les one man show c'est pas trop mon truc
qu'on était pliée de rire tous les deux
donc ça attire vraiment un public très
large
aussi bien je dis pas mon âge mon âge
que les plus jeunes donc vraiment c'est
puisqu'il est très très fort mais c'est
très bien vu c'est quelqu'un et qu'on
parle aussi de sa famille de son
histoire
voilà un oui c'est vraiment donc se font
tous publics et puis c'est drôle drôle
route de bohain portes au public
complètement alors c'est sûr qu'elle
prenne à michel drucker alors
certainement personne m'en diras pour
tous michel drucker il fait de l'effet
de la scène est en fait michel drucker
racontent toutes ces années de télé sur
scène et c'est très drôle aussi parce
qu'alors il alors lui il ne rencontrais
des gens connus connu connu et wii puis
tout le monde se souvient de la seine
entre gainsbourg et le fameux billet
voilà donc deux choses comme ça on a des
spectacles qui ont eu des molières cette
année et j'étais content de rester
vraiment pas malin récemment yvo livi
qui donnera contre l'avis d'yves montand
on a et demande alexis michalik alexis
michalik très connue maintenant qui a
débuté à avignon comme tout le monde
comme beaucoup et puis bien fait il a
grimpé énoncés comment edmond rostand a
écrit aurait écrit parce que joue un peu
avec l'histoire michalik aurait écrit
serrano de bergerac et c'est super alors
ça donne envie tout ça
une question me taraude c'est combien
bon allez pour venir voir une pièce de
théâtre là c'est vraiment c'est votre
moment là pour que c'est vrai tout
moment c'est gentil
l opération s plus ça dépend par exemple
pour à m sila
on s'est dit bon on pourrait le faire
carrément 35 40 euros la place à remplir
est mais à ce moment-là ça mettrait les
jeunes dehors
donc on s'est dit bon voilà on va plutôt
descendre le prix mais faire un seul
tarif donc à m sila ses 27 euros
l'accord par exemple madame c'est encore
abordable une pièce de théâtre ça pareil
ça dépend nous on calcule en fonction de
la possibilité de remplir
de la jauge de ce que le spectacle nous
a coûté allez on va dire nous on va pour
les enfants c'est vraiment pas cher
c'est 10 euros
et sinon pour le public c'est entre 25
et 35 euros
mais c'est une saison avec 26 spectacles
donc faut venir bien vous nous avez
donné envie mais en tout cas merci
d'être venu sur le plateau mais vous
restez avec nous avec vous jouer un peu
au handball ou pas du tout genre et la
taille il faut être grand pour lui non
pas forcément
mais bon je reste à des rebelles entre
où on reçoit sur le plateau cindy
rodrigues elle est là président du futur
club de handball et non hand ball je
fais souvent la faute de villepreux
celui ci devait voir le jour pour la
saison 2017-2018 staff et je me trompe
pas absolue alors dites-nous tout il y a
trois ans d qui peut y avait une équipe
de handball féminine
effectivement on avait une équipe sur
les clayes-sous-bois mais au niveau des
âges et c'est vraiment une période qui
est un peu compliquée surtout chez les
filles donc du coup on a perdu pas mal
de filles on s'est retrouvé trop peu
nombreuses pour pour avoir une équipe
donc ça a été un travail de longue
haleine de recruter des filles
donc ça s'est fait sur trois ans donc il
a fallu récupérer certaines filles
d'autres les récupérer ça a été c'est
sur cette année c'est vraiment majorité
de filles qui ont arrêté du coup à la
suite à la suite de la
la dissolution de cette équipe va fort
donc dans ce cadre là j'ai sollicité la
mairie de villepreux donc stéphanie
rambo et ses élus j'ai pu rencontrer
alexandrie est non et monsieur koshiki
sont délégués de la jeunesse et adjoint
aux sports dans le cadre de ville
provient en aide à ces jeunes où j'ai pu
leur leur proposer mon projet et puis
voir avec eux ce qui était possible de
faire ou mathieu présenter votre
dispositif est derrière avec ce qui est
possible ou non sur sur la ville de
villepreux
donc du coup ils ont même reçu ma
demande il
ils n'ont étudié ils m'ont proposé un
créneau pour la prochaine saison
un créneau d'entraînement un créneau de
match alors qu'ils peuvent venir
s'inscrire c'est de quel âge à quel âge
dites-nous tout alors c'est une équipe
féminine donc c'est exclusivement des
filles
on est sur une équipe plus 16 ans qu'il
faut avoir au minimum 16 ans pour
s'inscrire et il n'y a pas de ya pas de
limite d'âge particulière donc on est
sur une équipe où il va y avoir des
compétitions on va rencontrer d'autres
équipes tout au long de l'année et et
puis voilà le seul mot je pensais la
motivation il n'a pas d'autre à d'autres
actuellement combien y'a combien de
filles déjà qu'ils font partie de
l'équipe parce que vous avez créé deux
équipes tout de suite on commence déjà
par une saison et puis du coup on est
une quinzaine de filles pour l'instant
à être prête à
à monter cette équipe donc du coup on
fait aussi on participe au forum des
associations le 9 septembre à villepreux
qui permettra aussi de faire un peu plus
éco pour cette prochaine saison mais
pour l'instant d une quinzaine de filles
et vous serez dans quel championnat
alors on sera en honneur départemental
puisque comme on est sur une création de
clubs et une création d' équipe on
repart tout en bas de l'échelle et on
peut pas reprendre sur ce qu'on avait
fait avant
et puis notre but c'est vraiment de
d'évoluer de grimper et puis de mettre
vie pr sur le devant de la scène du
handball féminin parce que c'est une
ville qui se qui se modernise qui
s'agrandit donc je pense que le sport
féminin à boujan devint donc vous avez
un jour d'entraînement seul et les
matches ça ça m'a aidé parce que dans
votre tête en tout cas ce que je perçois
vous visez déjà alors dans un premier
temps ça va aller puisque bon on repart
doucement on recrute des filles aussi
qu'ils ont pas forcément vend déjà fait
du hand ou qui commence doucement
donc on part sur un entraînement le
jeudi donc sur un créneau adultes 20
heures à 22 heures et on aura des matchs
le week end dans un premier temps un
créneau vannes où j'ai une question dont
vous serez au forum des associations
imaginons que
une famille passe avec sa fille qui à 13
14 12 ans vous pouvez vous adaptez
pourront essayer
ah non on pourra pas on pourra pas la
recevoir étant donné qu'on est sur une
équipe senior donc une jeune fille kaka
12 13 ans c'est vraiment trop jeune au
niveau gabarit on va rencontrer trop de
trop de différence mais du coup on saura
la réorienter vers vers les clubs
voisins sans problème on l'espère va pas
la laisser sans sport si c'est son sport
vous voyez tout n'est pas perdu et la
suite c'est quoi alors il ya ce
championnat et vous voulez que j'imagine
faire grossir votre association ça va
être de quelle manière nous avant des
événements vous allez aller vers les
gens vous me parlez du forum des
associations alors oui effectivement on
va déjà faire le forum des associations
pour essayer de te recruter d'autres
filles qui auront envie d'y participer
pour l'instant on reste sur sur ce club
sur pour une seule équipe qui reste
seniors féminines d'accord pour finir en
termes de capacité là vous êtes 15 ça
vous pouvoir recruter encore combien à
une bonne dizaine me disait entre les
blessés les indisponibles on a de quoi
faire donne envie un petit peu au moins
de voir les matchs de voir les matches
j'ai dit ok bah je vous remercie
a donetsk est revenu sur le plateau
c'est la fente 7,8 les invités bonne
soirée à tous
[Musique]